this parallel that we have here is how
to cut carbon on how fast can we go our
panel is David Wright director
electricity transmission a chief
engineer of electricity the National
Grid Polly Billington is director of UK
100 Tim Lord as director of clean growth
at Beis and David Jaffe is economy-wide
analysis lead of the Committee on
climate change this is your first panel
over the morning please give them a
welcome so how to cut carbon and how
fast can we go David Wright well good
morning everybody
I'm delighted to just building on a
couple of Anjou's facts I think there's
a lot we can be proud of actually here
in the UK in the progress that's really
been made in how we have cut carbon
sixty-seven percent of those carbon
reductions that Andrew spoke about have
happened in the in the power sector and
it was only a few years ago I remember
the you know attending events like this
and the the conversation in the room was
we're never going to get to our 2020
target levels and we've got there of a
couple of years early and that's
happened through you know clear stable
policy that has enabled you know
contracts for differences and other
renewable generations to go forward and
that the UK at the moment were leading
the offshore wind industry around the
world and there's a production line of a
couple of gigawatts of offshore wind
getting connected to the system every
year moving forward we've built a number
of new interconnectors and a number of
others in the pipeline but not
everything is rosy and we've certainly
seen you know the nuclear industry
cannot get commercial funding to get
that away as a source of low carbon
generation at the moment but there's a
lot we can be proud of
I think we're currently decarbonized in
the UK faster than any of the other g20
countries so but then we look to the
future and you know what I and a number
of my colleagues at National Grid spend
a lot of time think
bow is you know we need to recognize the
changes that are going on in the world
and in people's lives and people delete
you know deserve to have clean air to
breathe and we deserve to find a way of
doing the energy transitions which is
going to impact on everybody's lives not
only in where energy is sourced from
today but how our homes are heated and
and how we transport and the cars we buy
if you will so it's going to be impact
on on everybody and we need to bring all
of those communities together and find a
way of doing that fairly so it's not
just the prosperous end of of society
that is benefiting so that's what we're
focusing on we really welcome David's
CCC report on Net Zero we believe this
is an ambition that the country needs to
progress and we can get there but to get
there it needs that stable policy
environment good regulation and and some
you know strong decision-making we also
think that there's real diversity in
what needs to be done in actual fact
getting to Net Zero makes the policy
framework I think a lot simpler because
a lot of things need to get progressed
and if you truly believe it a number of
that become low threats decision making
so we absolutely should be embracing all
of the local community-based generation
there was 275 energy companies in 2011
in the UK last time I checked that
numbers over 3,200 but we also need to
be finding ways to deliver the
transition at the least cost for the
country and that does mean you know
doing anticipate reinvestment where it's
appropriate to do it so that that
infrastructure is built out to enable
that energy climate to happen can you
diversify devolve the supply of
electricity and at the same time
keep the price down or doesn't that
automatically make it more expensive so
I think this comes down to a sort of
question about technology and innovation
you know I think if you get it right
we've seen huge changes in the cost of
solar driven by the investment in the
Chinese battery costs are absolutely
tumbling offshore wind was a hundred and
thirty pounds a megawatt a few years ago
the last CFD auction I think was 57 so I
think with the right investment and
timing the investment with a strong
policy environment I think there are
ways through that it'll be a challenge I
would think it will be a challenge and
what David's report identifies is
there's a significant amount of
investment needed in energy
infrastructure here in the UK to achieve
the net zeros and we shouldn't shy away
from that but I think the costs are
constantly moving David the other David
the official target is still to get net
emissions down by 80 percent but your
latest report advocated we go to net
zero emissions
what extra has to be I've never mind
getting into the 80% what extra has to
be done to get to net zero well the age
of scent reduction allowed some
remaining emissions in some sectors now
that could be heating for example or in
transport there are various different
ways you can cut it and that was
actually part of the problem with the
80% target is that you look at that and
you think well I want to be in the 20%
net zero means going as far as we can on
everything and still we will have some
remaining emissions and so in simple
terms just to clarify that means that to
get to Net Zero we stopped heating with
gas and we stopped cooking with gas with
natural gas yes but we can switch to
hydrogen for example so that would be
one of the options so that'll be able to
still very expensive it is
yes very expensive well at the moment
we're not doing at the scale that we
would require and if you do it scale
that we were to require then it will be
less cost even it
today but yes it's more expensive has
the government given you any indication
yet as to whether it's going to accept
the new the tougher target we've had no
formal indication about whether it's
going to happen or we all we know is
what's what we read in the newspapers
probably because their minds are
elsewhere just to clarify on this the
big change then in decarbonizing to get
to Net Zero brings the issue right into
the household
it does have survey yes has anybody told
the public this yet I think that this is
one of the big challenges that we have
the public seem to be very engaged in
terms of needing action on climate
change in terms of being willing to set
a very ambitious target but when it
comes to the actions that will be
required to meet it I think the puppet
quite a way behind where they need to be
for example moving away from natural gas
in the home whether that's to heat pumps
whether it's to hydrogen
most people don't know even that they're
going to have to move away from natural
gas
let alone what the solutions are and you
know whether it's hydrogen whether it's
heat pumps it will be more expensive
than what we do today because natural
gas is cheap and plentiful so there are
big decisions for government to make in
the 2020s and that's difficult if you
don't engage with the public this is
every chance you make the wrong decision
and people won't like it and it'll be
more expensive Bangladesh's you don't
want the backlash so you need to engage
with people before that and we have a
very limited window to do that because
the decisions need to be made in the
next five years or so and that yeah
that's a big challenge for government
Pauley as we gather here this morning
gas the fossil fuel is providing 60% of
our electricity generation wind is
providing four percent even the French
are providing as it was more electricity
than wind this morning that's just a
snapshot and there are other times last
night for example it was wind was almost
25 percent though in a sense that also
emphasizes the swings that wind and
itself can make but as we sit this
morning and see 60 versus 4 there are
other renewables too but not many on the
right these are National Grid figures
that have been
include some local generation we would
seem to have a long way to go even to
get to the 80 percent target nevermind
the net zero target I think it's worth
reminding ourselves that we've also had
a fortnight without any electricity
generated by coal which is the first
time we've had that since the 1880s and
when we talk about those fluctuations
the kind of power system we're going to
have in the future it's going to need to
deal with and not that that kind of
variation in where we get the energy
from at the time that's why as David has
pointed out the importance of battery
storage will mean that those things will
happen but what's important about the
things we've talked about not only
coming right into the home it's coming
to the community if you want to be able
to make this work you're going to have
to generate your electricity closer to
where it is used you're going to need to
make sure that that flexibility is as
local as possible and that will increase
the efficiency of what we're talking
about it has been extraordinary what
we've managed to do in terms of our
offshore wind industry over the last 10
years partly because of significant
signals to the market like contraband
and abandom support like contracts for
difference what is going to be the
equivalent of contract for difference
for local integrated clean energy
projects which will transform the places
in which we live that's not just our
home in a very individual way but the
communities that we live in because that
is where you will be able to balance not
only power but arguably other things
like heat because it's heat and
transport that happen in places and when
you get into decarbonizing the sexes
power is that we've done comparatively
well we've got a lot further to go as
your statistics indicate but if we go to
the next stage it's gonna be heating
power they are tricky because they
happen with people and unless we design
things for people and and and that's not
just on an individual consumer level but
also as a community we won't manage to
accelerate in the way that David has
pointed out we need to you said that the
future involves generating the power
closer to where it's being consumed that
was the system in Britain in the late
19th century up until the 1920s and it
was incredibly inefficient and
incredibly expensive yeah well it was
different technologies
I mean but we have to be honest with
ourselves no it's not a full answer
because the start of one thanks is it
yes explain how because the point is we
had in that we had an extraordinary
vision with the the introduction of the
National Grid and we need to have the
same kind of vision about what we're
going to be able to do next because we
cannot have we cannot rely on that side
kind of centralized system for our
electricity in the future we need to be
we identifying what the resources are in
particular places and making sure that
we're maximizing that for example Stoke
has done an extraordinary amount of work
on using their waste heat left over from
their from their ceramic industry that
means that they've now got a district
heating system which powers that which
heats the whole of their sent their
their town center that is partly owned
by the local authority they therefore
have income that is something which
people local authorities haven't thought
about for a very long time our network
includes 94 local authorities who are
making committing to climate action in
time for the in in line with their
science and those kind of innovations
mean that we will be thinking about the
resources in our communities and then
before we start thinking oh don't worry
we can literally offshore it to the
Arctic to the wind industry because yes
that will be crucial but it won't be the
only way we'll be able to power our
homes and our communities what do you
say that I think that's right I think in
some ways the transition which as you
say has been enormous ly impressive I
think we don't necessarily kind of
celebrate or focus on that achievement
enough in terms of leaving the g7
leading the g20 in the way that we've
decarbonized
the next phase is going to be more
challenging a lot of what we've done so
far has been about getting energy
infrastructure providers to build large
centralized energy infrastructure the
next stage of the challenge involves
consumers businesses and so on in a very
different way but I do agree very much
report with what Polly said that that
the the range of technologies is
shifting and that sometimes we present
this as a kind of binary set of
questions is it offshore wind or is it
gas for example is it centralized
generation is it distributed generation
actually local solutions will work in a
lot of in a lot of cases the active
activeness of the demand side will make
a big difference in terms of the
there's smart systems and so on that
National Grid and others are leading and
I think what we need to get away from is
that kind of binary technology versus
technology approach and one which
actually integrates different solutions
in different parts of the country but
what does a generating system look like
that is heading towards net zero is
there still gas generation I don't think
there's a single pathway to net zero but
I think there are and from the excellent
work that the Committee on climate
change to get in their recent report I
think that they've sketched out some of
this you're gonna need a lot of
low-carbon generation on that system of
course hello every new herbals and
offshore wind nuclear carbon capture
usage and storage becomes absolutely
critical I think in a NetZero context
you could sort of see how you could get
to 80% without it I think is extremely
good to see how you get it so Net Zero
without it I think you're gonna need a
much more responsive energy system a
much smarter energy system that is a
that's a kind of know losing service
right let me try to pin you down here
I'd start by reacting my question are we
gonna build more gas stations or not at
the moment we're building more gas
stations gas has an incredibly important
role as a transitional fuel was clearly
important if it's 61 percent of the
electricity this morning what I'm asking
you is are we going to continue to build
more or not and is that consistent with
aiming for net zero emissions topping
continued gas is absolutely consistent
with net zero emissions because it's got
a really important role to play over the
coming decades and then potentially it's
got a role to play and in the longer
term in combination with carbon capture
and storage episode but how can you get
to Net Zero of gas is still a major part
of our electricity generation I think I
think it's hard to see well we're
unabated gas provides that the level of
generation is providing now in a NetZero
context what I'm saying is there is a
really important role over the coming
decades as we transition to a lower
energy system and that with carbon
capture and storage gas potentially has
a role to play in the long term as well
and you make more of renewables by
increasing the amount of battery storage
because that's where we'll have to shift
so you make the flexibility which is so
important and that's one of the reasons
why we've relied on fossil fuel for so
long because you can switch it on and
off and what you'll need to do and is to
be able to store more so that you can
maintain that flexibility and develop
the smart grids that Tim's talked about
David do we have the technologies
battery technology to store vast amounts
so I mean there's a lot of points being
made across the panel and I agree with a
lot of the points but I just wanted to
try and round out a couple as well as
answering your questions so specifically
your question Andrew you know if the
cost of battery technology is coming
down drastically and there's a number of
different advancements in battery
technology about you know the rate of
charge the energy density you know the
power output divided by the weight of
the battery and so it's not only about
cost that's going on in the development
of battery technology so batteries are a
really really interesting technology in
all of david' scenarios come forward as
as very important I absolutely agree
with Polly's points as well about the
need for local community and whole
system solutions involving heat and
waste electric vehicle charging as well
as how we source our individual power
but you know if you were to take a
standard UK domestic home you know to
have enough power generated from solar
power for that home and you would need
to pour solar panels not only on the
roof of your house but for of your
neighbors and you'd need to have the
Tesla 10 kilowatt hour power walls you
need to have about 170 of them to get
you through an average window and then
you'd have no resilience or redundancy
associated with it so the scale of what
you would need in some of these
scenarios are quite large now that will
move and that will change in five years
time battery technology will have moved
on from where it is today in David's
scenarios for Net v Net Zero we see a
doubling of the electricity demand
across the UK we go from eight gigawatts
of offshore wind connected to over 70
gigawatts so you know the size and the
scale of the energy shifts that are
really needed to get to Net Zero need to
embrace all of these different
technology solutions and I absolutely
agree with with the speakers last point
that you know we should
don't need to be making arbitrary
technology choices and having one
element competing against another if we
truly believe as we do that we need to
get to Net Zero and get ourselves on a
pathway I think we need to focus on what
other decisions we need to be taking
today where do we need to be
accelerating those technologies which
are cost-effective and are providing the
solutions for tomorrow at the key
transformation that needs accelerating
in my view it now is there is the
decarbonisation of transport you know
that is on the cusp of hitting us
mainstream and we need to make sure that
we've got the charging infrastructure
that we need because that will in that
will result in the huge increase in
demand for electricity it will result in
an increasing demand of electricity it
will be staggered though because you
know the rate of electric at the rate of
new vehicle ownership in the UK is about
two and a half million a year and
there's 36 million cars in the UK today
so in any scenario you know it's gonna
take 10 15 years to go from pretty much
where I think it's it's what you know a
couple of percent still today in the UK
number of electric vehicles to where it
needs to get to so and over that kind of
time scale we have got the time to build
out those generation low-carbon
generation sources in order to be able
to meet that electricity demand Polly
would you say to David's remarks about
battery power I basically agree with him
I mean the idea that you would only be
depending on solar it's a good example
of what the implications are of curve
they're kind of a generation you need
but we're talking about a mix and that's
what's important commercial if did so
also to the the question here of the
politics of this because if we want to
do this stuff fast which is what what is
probably required then we're going to
need to start escalating our ambition
and there's an opportunity here for the
leadership contenders in the Tory Party
to commit to net zero now whoever lead
whoever wins that leadership should make
that their first piece of legislation
because we know that this is actually
something which sends a very strong
message to people who are concerned
about climate change that things need to
happen and then we need to get down into
the really really difficult tricky stuff
about making sure that people understand
what this means for the for their
lifestyles and we need to focus and this
is why then it's important to build on
that for put in terms of transport this
needs to be about the co-benefits I know
that since the climate strikes and the
extinction rebellion and so forth
demonstrations that the awareness and
anxiety about climate change has
increased but broadly speaking
standardly about 18 percent of people
say they will vote on environmental
issues and roughly about half of them
are lying we can't build a majority
story about this through only focusing
on the people who are deeply anxious
about it it has to become a mainstream
thing so what does that mean for my hob
my fridge my kettle those kind of things
which are deeply in individualistic as
well as what does that mean for how I
get to school to work how what kind of
work do I do what kind of subjects to my
kids study at school those are the
things that give us an opportunity to
have a grand sense of national mission
we will only do that if we manage to
establish a consensus about this and I
think that's an opportunity that there
at the moment when this is a country
that is deeply divided if there's one
thing that really requires the kind of
things that everybody says Britain is
good at international leadership and
techno and Technology technological
innovation those kind of things
everybody should be able to agree on at
a time of division and that is something
that whoever is in power should be able
to start to establish and make sure that
it isn't just something that happens at
a national level but also you really
harness the ambition that there is at
local level to make this happen because
if you don't do that then it will be
top-down people will resist and you'll
end up again with a I don't want this to
happen and that will be very damaging
for not only happy achieving this in
line with the science but potentially
politically as well well but the Tory
yeah but what does it mean because the
Tory candidates can say all they want
about zero emissions but you cannot go
to the people until you have the policy
implications of what zette net zero
emissions will be and that's where I'm
trying to establish this morning so let
me go back to David David Jaffe here and
ask you for example in getting to net
zero emissions
does nuclear pass still have a rope they
potentially dose yes and truly does
that's a politician's answer does it or
doesn't it well the thing about the
electricity system is we have options so
Jim will give the answer on on what the
current government thinks in our
modeling we do have nuclear in there
we have much nuclear well in our
scenario that we present it but it's
only indicative we have around 10
gigawatts in 2050 but we've said that
could be up to 25 gigawatts by 2050 and
that depending on choices so that would
involve building more nuclear stations
yes on existing sites so the the energy
technology institute has has already
identified the existing sites when we
generally that's policy for what is it
really saleable after the agreement that
Hinkley Point would have guaranteed
prices of twice the market rate in
perpetuity
and we don't even know if it's gonna be
built on time or on cost because every
other one EDF has done recently from
Helsinki to flan ville in northern
France has been anything but on time or
on cost indeed has been it makes the
this new central line in London look a
beacon of infrastructure spending there
Helsinki was made open I think in 2009
that's a decade do you think that's
conceivable is that a policy that you
can sell the politicians are going to
stand up and defend
I think that's usually challenging with
that reactor design so I think the
question is well how do we get nuclear
to a cost where it can actually
contribute to a sensible low-cost
generation mix and that might be
different reactor designs it might be
moving away from the current one Tim
Lord the government presided over the
first the new build of nuclear power for
quite some time is very expensive I've
seen some studies suggesting it is the
most expensive Power Station in the
history of the world you got the stomach
to do another one like that so I think
we are supported in UK in case expensive
it's also going to provide 7% of our
electricity demand it's a very very
large project as you say it's the first
one in a generation and there's a real
challenge in terms of getting that that
supply chain
up and running again as I said before
learning games right you know this isn't
about saying it's gonna be X giggle to
one Synology in 2050 and Y gigawatts of
another we need to be able to make sure
we're adapting to what's happening to
those technologies over time and I think
it's very clear if it for nuclear and
for all technologies delivering Cost
Reduction demonstrating ability to
deliver not just the first of a kind
that then project not a project is going
to be absolutely critical to that but
that blend of technologies is important
nuclear has a really important role in
providing thanks low-power
in a way that renewables I understand
the importance of that that's not my
argument and indeed as part of the
energy mix nuclear power has been the
base load power but our existing fleet
of nuclear stations is coming to the end
of its life this morning it's still
providing over twenty percent of our
electricity five times this morning what
wind is doing but they will have to be
phased out a number already have been
and I've just I'm just trying to get
before I come on to the issue of
consumers and then go to the audience
I'm just trying to get a picture to help
the audience get a picture of what will
a generation supply system look like as
we head to net zero emissions so it will
have a lot of low carbon generation on
the system both renewables I would
anticipate nuclear carbon capture and
storage I think it will have to be
hugely more flexible and that includes
battery storage it includes a much more
responsive demand side in particular and
I suspect that the centralized
generation will continue to play a
really important role I think you know
David's talked about the number of solar
panels and power ball's you need if you
do this with a fully decentralized
system but it'll be a combination and I
think an increasing combination of
centralized and distributed sure
productions quite general let me come
today because you you the grid as our
main distributor of power must have
given a lot of thought to this as we as
because as I understand the National
Grid it's signed up to the decarbonizing
of our electricity generation the
decarbonizing array of our economy which
must have huge implications for Europe
business tell us how you see the future
so I I think when we we look at four
different energy scenarios for the
future and the electricity system
operator which is now separate from the
net
works put those out each year and they
recognizes a range of future scenarios
there's no doubt in my mind the the
niccola flea is going to decrease as it
comes to the end of its life and EDF
have done a good job actually of
extending the life of the nuclear
stations but there's only so much you
can you can do associated with that but
at the same time there's been a lot of
demand responsive behavior happening at
times of winter peak which is reduced
the size of the overall electricity
Peaks as we move into the
electrification of transport that's
going to change you know and we'll see
electricity demand start to increase
again in the UK we're seeing a massive
growth in the volume of interconnectors
national grill grids built three there's
another three currently getting built
and a number of others getting built by
other companies as well and that's a
sort of balance against that wind and
solar so you know and they're not all to
France you know there's one to Denmark
that's getting built has one to Norway
that's getting bills one to Ireland that
it never seems to send as anything the
Irish energy market is a very small
energy market
it's very diplomatic it's four gigawatts
compared with you know over 50 gigawatts
here in the UK so do we insist as we
build these interconnectors that the par
they're sending as is carbon free so we
can't but island are actually doing
really really well they're not sending
what about the others oh no ways this
morning the French are sending is 4.6
the Irish nothing the Dutch 3% for the
east with the east-west interconnector
which one is what's that
anyway it's ending is nothing so it
doesn't matter I'm just
what because one of the hip would say
that again
yeah well that's island - yeah that's
why it's nothing right because one of
the hypocrisy
when mrs. Merkel panicked after the
Japanese disaster nuclear disaster and
just suddenly announced the closing of
all Germany's nuclear power stations was
that she imported power from
Czechoslovakia nuclear power from the
Czech Republic in other words so I would
have thought people here to get to net
emissions would like to know that power
that we are importing is subject to the
same net zero target as what we're
trying to build ourselves well as you
know Angie the Paris Accord is applying
across the world is apply across Europe
different countries are moving forward a
different pace the reality is though is
if you really believe in decarbonizing
the UK and going after those renewable
sources of generation you need a
flexible network which can cope with
those times when the wind is blowing or
the sun is shining but can also cope
with those times when it's not and
that's where the value of
interconnectors comes because we are an
island nation we are not on an infinite
European bus by electricity grid and
flexibility is really really important
if you get in a decarbonize the UK's
electricity mix you know you cannot
store in vast quantities yeah
electricity you have to balance it
second-by-second up Tim it and then Poli
look at the consumer or if I could
almost see the voter implications for
this because they're not often talked
about if we're to move to Z net zero
emissions I am I writing in saying we
have to move by 2050 250 overwhelmingly
to electric vehicles an electric
transport including even white van man
will have to be electric that's point
one will need to think I see mr. e Devi
interesting ideas I was calling he's
saying that we shouldn't be flying
internally
that's obviously a clear attack on Joe
Swinson position see it's just outside
Glasgow but that's another potential
implication we will have to give up our
gas heating system and our gas cooking
system these are all and we may there's
a bit about this but so far in the
public mind because of what happened to
heat it to power bill fuel bills is that
all this means bigger foot bills all
this is more expensive the consumer will
pay the state may pay a bit but the
consumer is going to have to pay a lot
more - you add all that together that's
quite a hard sell I think is the
challenge when you wouldn't you would
expect me to comment too much on the
politics but I think I would absolutely
agree that you know as I said earlier
this phase of decolonisation debate has
been less about sort of real impacts on
consumers the next phase I think will be
different I think what you are seeing is
clearly a real up swelling concern about
climate change I think people are
becoming better informed about climate
change I think one of the big challenges
for the next 10 5 to 10 years is gonna
be about how you translate that into
consumers understanding how that is
going to impact on them I think it is
worth saying first of all and Polly
mentioned k benefits ed and all of these
things are bad by any stretch of the
imagination people buying electric
vehicles tend to say they like them they
they like the consumer experience of
them and they're doing it people can't
afford them at the moment most people on
earth for them but the cost of batteries
is coming down and most people expect
that crossover point to happen within
the next few years so it doesn't have to
be a more costly outcome it's also worth
saying you know one of the biggest
emission savings we've had in recent
years hasn't has been the power sector
it's been in boilers where changes to
board a regulation meant that we've
saved hundreds of tons of only tens of
mega tons of carbon over recent years
and in a change that consumers didn't
necessarily really notice even though it
was then that was delivering it and I
think government's gonna need to be very
intelligent in the way that it looks at
that set of questions and the
combination of tools that it uses to
deliver it it may be to that people
should realize that with an electric
vehicle or the moment they up some cost
is high the running cost substantially
Lord but Polly how do you see because
this has barely entered our public
debate we have debates
at a policy level of should we have
nuclear should we still build gas should
we continue with on shore when do we
need to do even more offshore wind
should we do interconnect that's five
that happens within the square mile of
here we haven't taken this to the public
yet well I think you're right I think
there is a a very sort of technical
conversation for those of us who are
very very interested in energy however
when you talk about climate change for
example I did a run of interviews on
local radio around the time of David
Attenborough's fantastic documentary and
almost every last question and the whole
round was well if people are really
anxious about this what should they do
and you know it was live radio I wasn't
gonna swear but it shouldn't be the fact
that we are talking about internalizing
and individualizing this there is a
because or i can say to people eat less
meat fly less get on with it but mostly
it's about putting pressure on your on
the politicians to make some of these
big decisions so that you can get those
things done because tim's right about
the boilers and what's very interesting
is i'm not sure that people are
massively wedded to their boilers i
don't think they're going to march for
heat pumps but I think managing to get
from oh no I must hold onto my boiler I
don't think people feel like that I
think they want to make sure that their
home is affordable for themselves and to
the planet and that and that they feel
warm and we know that that those kind of
things make sure that we can get that
that shift over now it's still expensive
and that's where we've got to we've got
to make the we've got to make some big
decisions and that's where and central
and local government come in about
sending some strong signals to the
market yes you might remain lead to
subsidize things it's interesting you
say that about the Eevee's that it's
it's cheaper to run well it is for the
time being while they're VD exempt at
some point if there's enough of an
uptake HMT is gonna start saying that's
going to have to change and also where
is the EP infrastructure charging in
order for people to be has a few yes
there is but but you still have you
still don't have a car you still don't
have road tax if you
evie that's partly a subsidy to well
exactly but that's what I'm saying if
that's if that goes because HMT suddenly
realizes they're they're losing that
that income then they're going to then
they're going to shift over and so so I
think we need to if you if you're
talking about big strong signals do
stuff which showed that only government
can do or only government can facilitate
it doesn't well even infrastructure
that's gonna have a big implication for
the National Grid because of the demand
on it but unless you feel that you can
you're going to be able to plug in while
you go to the shops or that you can
leave it somewhere overnight and it's
going to be there in the morning and
it's going to be able to be charged then
people are not going to feel confident
about it can I also point out that in
the CCC's report on this they were very
keen on v's for individual use but there
wasn't an emphasis on public transport
and it was in a healthy healthy active
active lifestyles walking and cycling
fine but that dare I say is a bit of a
zone one approach right if anybody's
been outside even beyond zone 2 zone 3
in London let alone trying to get in and
out of Derby or Sheffield on an act on a
standard commuter run we're gonna have
to put much more investment in public
transport and data let me say again if
you're talking about a strategic code
benefit you're talking about rebalancing
the UK economy there's one thing that
ended up with us in this kind of pickle
we are politically it's the lack of
balance in the UK economy and strong
investment in public emphasis in public
transport infrastructure in a beyond
London is really important if you want
to make sure partly the electrification
partly more optional and also just have
some witty wait witty and savvy ways of
making sure that people will use what
they've got in Liverpool they've made
sure that all all students get to
reduced bus fares but also they've put
wheat free Wi-Fi on it that's a really
really simple way of making sure that
kids won't ask to be able to go in the
car if they they can actually start
using the buses if you want to be able
to shift people's behaviors you need to
make sure that it's not just about
virtue but it actually is value for
money
we have free Wi-Fi here so tweet as much
as you wander but what you're hearing
and let me go to the audience and get
some questions
we have a microphone there and we have
another one there and we have one there
we have a plethora of microphones
gentleman in the white shirt there and I
keep a hand up and I get another my own
the gentleman in the blue shirt there
keep your hand up and the lady down here
nope we've got if you could bring the
microphone to the women there yes sir
thanks very much Peter Smith from
National Energy Action a fuel poverty
charity I want to pick up the question
about affordability for particular for
the poorest households Treasury
currently makes a large fortune out of
carbon taxes can the Treasury maintain
its current approach of essentially
paying for all of the energy transition
through consumer bills energy consumer
bills and how urgent priority is a need
to invest in ambitious energy efficiency
program to reduce the costs for the
poorest households who would you like to
answer that question Jim absolute you
could I think the CCC reports really
interesting on this because what it
shows is that Net Zero
broadly speaking can be achieved back in
2008 but clearly within that able to
decide how to distribute those costs and
be that you know if we don't do anything
about there will be significant winners
and losers and I'll see the CCC
recommended you know precisely to your
point that the Treasury carry out a
review of how we do that will obviously
set out opposition on that on the net
zero in in due course but I think that's
certainly something that we'd want to
look at hard because I think you're
right that the overall approach around
consumer bills and the importance of
protecting the fuel pool and those least
able to pay in particular is critical so
they should change the often rules they
should change the off game rules I mean
one of the things is that at the moment
the of Jim is doing this equity only
about current consumers rather than
long-term the costs are going to go up
exponentially if we only worry about
what happens now and we'll learn and
rather than and that therefore builds in
a disadvantage of being able to make the
shift in a fair way because they're only
talking about equity now I mean in terms
of the energy efficiency we know that
the energy efficiency is the easiest way
of being able to decarbonize but the
incentive to do so
is low they should be they should be
devolving the Eco to local authorities
so they can do stuff within their own
social housing create a supply chain so
it means that they're able to pay can
get on with doing what needs to be done
because that would have been but would
have been proof there are a couple of
things that wouldn't take much for an in
order to be to be able to indicate that
net zero is serious about being both
about equity now and equity in the
future well let me come back to Tim we
know that for those on lower incomes
fuel bills are real worrying and they
take like food and fuel are the two
things you don't have a choice of that
you've got to put food on the table and
you got to heat your house in in winter
you have to cook and they take a big
percentage of lower-income expenditure
than they do of affluent people most of
whom people like in this hall so one way
that you could change that or to help
and I think it goes to the question that
you're asking is to have a massive
installation program of these homes
which would a create lots of jobs be cut
co2 emissions I assume because we
juicing less electricity and have I
would have thought quite a dramatic
effect on the fuel bills of the poor is
that right what what bit of that don't
you get I get all of it and so why
aren't you doing it so why you I'm you
are the government this morning
that is a bit mean on Tim so but was
that because that would seem to be
win-win-win so I think that is
absolutely a really important we are
doing a lot on this already we have you
know probably mentioned eco we have
reorient sated eco to purely focus on
the fuel poor and on innovation to try
and bring forward some of the innovative
how many houses are we improving the
installation for a year so I have to
check that number but we're investing
640 million a year through Eco so not a
lot six hundred million is a reasonably
large amount and that builds on
investment over the last over 10 years
the Chancellor loses a rounding error
every day in the Treasury
I'd have to defer to the Chancellor on
that but we are yes sir in the blue
shirt yeah so it's obviously essential
that it's actually the world that cuts
co2 emissions we won't achieve any
benefit from climate change with that
and the panel have mentioned quite a lot
about the role for UK leadership in
helping to do that but the rest of the
world can't as a whole import
electricity from overseas the rest of
the world cans as a whole offshore their
industrial emissions so what can the UK
do that will most encourage the rest of
the world to cut co2 emissions so we
actually do avoid dangerous climate
change
David Joffe there's a few things that we
can do one is to demonstrate leadership
by setting in that zero target and
taking the policy actions that really
demonstrate that we're serious about
meeting it that leadership can then
transfer into the EU context where
they're considering a net zero target
and have further influence in terms of
actions that we can take in the UK you
will agree with this John carbon capture
and storage is a big thing that we can
take action on - to actually say well
it's not just about the low-hanging
fruit it's not just about the other
tricity generation and the low cost
renewables and the electric vehicles
that we know are going to be cheap it's
actually how do we get to Net Zero and
that means doing the difficult things it
means getting rid of those but haven't
we just cut the investment in carbon
capture and storage we have twice
and explain to me how that is filed
under the leadership
well the unless you've gone backwards so
the the you cane now has a a plan to
demonstrate carbon capture and storage
by the mid-2020s I don't know what that
means
well III don't I don't know yet what it
means either I'm not in the government
but I'm hoping they're serious about it
I mean in 2008 the CCC recommended that
CCS should be demonstrated urgently
you know we're 11 years on from that and
it hasn't been yet the net zero target
makes it absolutely a necessity and if
we're serious about meeting it we need
to make progress and carbon capture and
storage and that means rolling out the
infrastructure in the 2020s not just in
one place now but probably in in
multiple places multiple we think well
the politics of this are not Frances
planning to set a net zero target in
July I understand that the UK wants to
beat France because that's the kind of
thing that the UK wants to do the
government is now having second thoughts
about that
well week 22 of the Julie Zhang sure
well we'll see how that plays out but
nevertheless if the UK daughter and then
France does it that's then strengthes
sends a strong signal to the rest of the
EU if the EU then commits to a net zero
target which the Commission has proposed
then there's momentum in this and that
can have impact more widely in the world
I'd like to make another point as well
which is the point about pollution so
yes there is a worldwide leadership you
know other developed the countries can
see what we're doing around the world
but there's also that you know clean
growth creating jobs here in the UK deep
polluting UK cities and I'm not just
talking about London I am talking about
those great northern cities we've got
and and level izing if you will and
bring that fairness if you will back
across UK society so I think there's a
huge bunch of reasons why we should be
doing this as well as showing that
leadership to the broader world which is
where the questioner was okay
they let me go to the women here in the
second row thanks Clem Calton from
octopus energy in the interest of moving
away from so listicles of different
generation technologies how does the
panel think that we can create a market
framework of time abuse and location of
use price signals that allow it can you
speak up a little bit how do we create a
market framework of time of use in
location abuse price signals that can
incentivize the kind of technology
agnostic approach for green electrons
moving short distances over uncongested
wires and in particular how can we
ensure that households are able to both
contribute to and benefit from that
market framework who would like to
answer that that's a David and Tim
please David okay well let me start I'd
like to congratulate you for the
simplicity that you've shown on your own
electricity bills which shows the tariff
difference
overnight compared with day as well as
what an individual customer which other
symbols of these different this is
octopus Energy's own electricity ability
you know it is the clearest indication
of what is actually going on that I've
seen and it's generally that I think
smart meters is is a really interesting
topic which comes to a couple of things
that the panel of Audis spoken about
this morning because smart meters give
the UK the opportunity to really
understand the cost of electricity
generation in each half hour period of
the day but we've not engaged with the
public
we've not explained that the vast
majority of the average public has a
single tariff that runs the same all the
way through the day and this comes to
the point of needing to engage with the
UK consumers about what actually goes on
in the marketplace and why smart meters
for example are part of the answer
moving forward you also so I think
there's a need for an industry-wide
debate
and that knowledge base if you will and
then I think that we'll start to see the
changes going on and on the time of use
on the geographic use I think it comes
back to a political actually a position
you know if you were talking to a
Scottish Nationalist MP you would you
would hear a lot of annoyance actually
that the cost of electricity is greater
in Scotland that it is say in the
southwest and that's because it costs
money to transport the electrons from
where they're generated to where they're
consumed so off Gemma's in my view
correctly a factor that into the bill if
you will so that you know the cost is
incurred most by worries where he's
using the right incentives on the
industry as a whole that's a political
and a fairness issue as well though but
also in Scotland there are community
energy projects projects they're really
struggling to get any any way forward
because they're not able to benefit from
that more it's been I like able to say
to their next-door neighbor will sell it
to you cheaper because it's so expensive
to get it from the transition
transmission grid there was no way of
local energy product projects being able
to their local community yeah so so the
cost of building those large and
connectors from remote areas into the
main grid has a cost and when off Jim
look at that individual cost what
they're saying is there isn't a
cost-benefit equation that makes sense
if you will overall to put that
connection in so it comes back to what
you're trying to optimize which comes
back to the political question I think
so the cheapest economic solution if
that's what you're trying to optimize
means that interconnector or that
circuit to the remote island in Scotland
doesn't get built if you're going for
complete levelized and everybody having
access to be able to do what they want
to in their individual community then
you level eyes the cost of connecting
regardless of where you are geography so
it comes back to a political question
a political decision that the government
needs to send a message to off Germans
at that issue about equity of not just
now but in the future needs to change
because unless you do that you're going
to end up with with local deeds of
decentralized energy projects at a
disadvantage and we won't make the shift
we need let me get a few more questions
before we there gentlemen
in the dark sweater up at the back up
there up to the back and gentlemen the
white shirt and no over there up there
up there yes sir I'm chandala Fernando
Innovation Centre at De Montfort
University what is the role of tax both
the split between the consumer and the
producer because it seems to me from
everything that has been said today
there will be vast capital investment
require required whether it's subsidized
by the government or not and at some
point you either have to tell business
well here is your subsidy and some to
keep the price down and for the consumer
whether we like it or not we are going
to find based on what you've said a
significant increase in the cost or the
selection and cost of energy that we
choose to use between between between
financial incentives and look at where
those costs are borne that's gonna be a
challenge here in the UK so it's gonna
be a challenge globally we want to do
things like industrial competitiveness
has a lot of people talking about common
order taxation those kind of thing those
are all the kinds of things we can add
we're going to have to have to look at
because there is an issue as I said
earlier about the way that we balance
these costs across the economy to make
sure they're manageable if I can add by
2050 we expect some of these things to
be cheaper than what we do today so for
example through new renewable
electricity the electric vehicles there
will be areas where the costs are higher
but you know it's up to government to
make that to make that case but there's
a crucial thing
might rightly or wrongly they believe
all of what we were talking about will
mean more for them because that's been
their experience until now they've seen
this reflected in their electricity fuel
bills so absolutely say they may be
wrong about the future but people will
generally be guided by what they know so
far and they've seen their bills go up
and we'll we'll see that journey through
the 2020s as as the cost of electricity
starts to come down because some of the
expensive subsidies that were paying
before come off bills but the the good
news story in the 2020s is that electric
vehicles will become cheaper than petrol
vehicles people will start to see the
benefits not only in terms of tackling
climate change also reduced a pollution
but also in their pocket they will see
that this is cheaper for them but David
we we're going to have to double the
capacity of the grid maybe more than
double the capacity of the grid can that
really be done without extra cost
without consumers having to pay more so
I think there's no question in my mind
there is a huge investment needed in our
energy our transport infrastructure here
in the UK we're going to decarbonize the
UK I think we can look at forward cost
curves and we can look at today's prices
and we can scare ourselves sometimes
about the size of that future cost
because there's going to be a lot of
technological innovation and we've seen
you know cost factors on solar and
offshore wind on storage absolutely
change dramatically but you're right
there is a huge investment needed and
it's a political decision as to whether
that is paid for by the public purse or
whether that goes on to consumer bills
we talked earlier about taxation I think
the Chancellor gets something like 26
billion pounds worth of Taxation at the
moment from petrol now that's a fugitive
and that's even after having frozen it
in real terms for certain so I spoke
earlier about having clear policy
decisions or directional to see
associated with how some of these things
are going to play out so you know today
get an electric vehicle you save a lot
you can charge it overnight it actually
you know if you can afford the capital
cost of the upfront you can you can save
a lot of money that's why London taxi
drivers are welcoming the transition
over to electric vehicles but that isn't
sustainable unless we can see that
future direction of what that taxation
policy is likely to be okay but but we
shouldn't scare people about the future
but we should I want to have one more
question and then we're gonna have to
end this panel and go straight to the
next one hi there how do you get the
right policy for carbon pricing post
breaks it because we need a new policy
don't don't all rush so we're consulting
at the moment on what the potential
future models should I think
carbon pricing is obviously been a
massively important driver of emission
reduction through through the ETS and
through the carbon price floor one
reason why I call is no barely feet tree
yeah absolutely and generators we've
gone from 40% of coal there any six
years ago to 2-0 now so it's so hugely
impactful I think you probably wouldn't
expect me to give a very specific answer
at this point given where we are on on
negotiations on brakes it and so on
that's what that answer looks like what
I think you know we're consulting on
what some different models look like we
think carbon pricing is a really really
important part of the policy mix in
terms of delivering emission reductions
particularly in the power sector and in
the industrial sector and I think it
will continue to play that role exactly
what that looks like post-op house Dux
it will be very nice to see the
responses to the consultation and
obviously that'll be part of the wider
negotiation Andrew can I give a very
personal answer to that you know we
factor in the true cost of carbon into
all of our investment decisions and it
started to change some of our
investments that we make within National
Grid and and I think it needs that
signal around what the future cost of
carbon is so other businesses dissimilar
David right Polly Billington Tim Lord
David Jovi thank you for giving us an
excellent start our first panel round of
applause for our
[Applause]